[Music]
Kevin Hart opening up about his kids
and repairing his relationship with his
own father on Monday night's Late Show
with Stephen Colbert for daddy cousins
feel about you my kids yo my kids think
I'm dope and that's what makes me happy
like my kids actually think I'm the
coolest dad on the planet but I know why
I am the way that I am see my dad has a
lot to do with that in Kevin's new
memoir I can't make this up life lessons
the comedian dedicates the book to his
late mother who raised him while his dad
was absent from his life the mistakes
that my dad made you know the decisions
to do drugs
being out of jail in and out of our
lives I saw firsthand with not being
present did and because of that I now
know what being present means I know
what that can do I know the effect that
I don't have on your child coming up now
I was strong enough to deal with it
coming up because I have a different
attitude I'm I'm a positive guy I choose
to go positive instead of negative a lot
and because of that my relationship with
my dad is is amazing now and my dad
understands how I feel and how I look at
things and now my dad is focusing on
being the best grandparents so you're
Eddie paws dad I've gotten back together
yes yes healed your relationship well
that's beautiful yeah that doesn't often
happen no it does it but I think there's
a choice you always you always have a
choice to make
my thing is I don't have time to be
angry you know much time and take the
hold attitude in a grudge that's time
and energy I don't have that time the
time that it takes you to go I don't
like that person and keep that in you
over a period of time it's a lot of time
that can be devoted to something
positive